JUST LIKE JODY FOSTER'S
CHARACTER IN THE MOVIE CONTACT,
SCIENTISTS HAVE COME ACROSS A
MYSTERIOUS SIGNAL FROM A GALAXY
FAR, FAR AWAY.
IN A STUDY PUBLISHED ON
WEDNESDAY, THE JOURNAL NATURE
SAID THAT THEY HAVE DETECTED A
VERY UNUSUAL RADIO BURST.
IT HAS A PATTERN THAT IS
SIMILAR TO A HEARTBEAT.
AND FOR NOW, THE EXACT LOCATION
AND CAUSE OF THAT BURST IS
UNKNOWN.
I WANT TO BRING IN CNN'S TOM
FOREMAN TO DISCUSS.
TOM, THIS STRANGE AND
PERSISTENT RADIO SIGNAL SEEMS
LIKE A PULSING HEARTBEAT.
WHAT PHENOMENON CAN CAUSE THIS?
DO WE KNOW OF ANYTHING THAT
CAUSES SIMILAR EFFECTS IN THE
UNIVERSE?
>> WE DO.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS ABOUT A
BILLION LIGHT YEARS AWAY, OR IN
SCIENTIFIC TERMS, REALLY REALLY
FAR.
AND THEY THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING CALLED A FAST RADIO
BURST, OR AN F R B.
THEY KNOW IT'S THAT, IT'S
PICKED UP A RADIO TELESCOPES ON
EARTH.
THEY ONLY DISCOVERED IN 2007.
BASICALLY, WHAT THIS IS A
LITTLE BURST OF ENERGY COMING
THROUGH THE COSMOS OUT THERE.
NORMALLY, THESE ARE VERY, VERY
SHORT.
MILLISECONDS LONG.
THIS ONE IS UNUSUAL BECAUSE IT
IS VERY STRONG, IT'S VERY
BRIGHT AS THEY SAY.
AND IT LASTED THREE SECONDS.
THAT'S AN AWFUL LOT OF
INFORMATION TO LOOK AT.
AND THEY ARE LOOKING AT VERY
CLOSELY RIGHT NOW, BIANCA.
IF YOU ASK WHAT IT MIGHT BE?
THE REAL QUESTION WOULD BE THE
SOURCE IS MOST LIKELY GOING TO
BE A VERSION OF A DYING STAR
OUT THERE, AS IT PASSES AWAY.
THESE STORIES CAN GIVE OFF
RADIO SIGNALS OUT THERE.
THOSE GIVE THESE SIGNALS OFF.
BUT THOSE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
TO KNOW ABOUT BECAUSE IF YOU
KNOW WHERE THEY ARE, IF YOU GET
ONE AS STRONG AS THIS AND YOU
CAN FIGURE OUT WHERE IT IS, IF
YOU CAN PINPOINT IT, YOU MIGHT
BE ABLE TO TRIANGULATE IT AND
GET A SENSE OF HOW FAST THE
UNIVERSE IS EXPANDING.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE SO EXCITED
ABOUT THIS.
IT'S NOT JUST A NOVELTY, IT'S
NOT SOMETHING FROM A MOVIE, BUT
SOMETHING IN REAL LIFE THEY
HAVE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
AND WITH THAT REPEATED PATTERN
IN THERE, THAT HEARTBEAT SOUND,
IT'S VERY EXCITING TO THE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY.
>> HUGELY EXCITING.
AND TO LAYMAN